does micromanaging ever work well yes
and and more importantly does it work
yes sometimes it works and more
importantly sometimes you have to
micromanage so you get somebody that
isn't good at their job doesn't do a
good job doesn't show up doesn't run
things right of course you know how you
fix them you gotta get in there
micromanage well first of all you can't
do mission failure so you got to get in
there micromanage
once you're done micromanaging or or
once you've got them up to speed then
you can stop micromanaging this is this
is totally good to go
and even if you asked life or you know
the other platoon commanders that work
for me or assistant platoon commanders
that work for me if when we stake out to
know me when they met me I was
micromanage master because I'm in their
grill hey this you got to do this no
come over here a little bit no and
wouldn't give any slack but then as soon
as I see that they get it
of course then it's like okay you got
this you got this and I'm gonna I'm
gonna macro manage and barely manage and
let them run with it and so that's
that's absolutely micromanagement is
sometimes it's a necessity and by the
way if you're getting micro managed
that's a little bit of a red flag sure
you might have somebody that's a control
freak that is a compulsive micro manager
and that sucks but you also might have
somebody that doesn't trust you yet and
so how do you build up their trust is it
by hiding from them no it's by being
open and being like hey boss here's what
I'm gonna do you actually send them more
information than they could even want
you show them how responsible you are
you show them what a handle you have on
the situation and that's how you can
help overcome the micro manager but if
someone's not doing what they're
supposed to or they're failing or
they're they're letting you down then
yeah you got to get in their grill and
micro manager the other time that sort
of said this is when you're mentoring
someone that can also be viewed as
micromanagement because now I'm sitting
side by side I might be breathing down
your neck a little bit and that might be
viewed as micromanagement but again
sometimes it's necessary if you don't
know the ropes yet I got to show you the
ropes that means I got to sit by you and
make sure you know it teaching so if
you're teaching somebody something in a
work environment that can also be viewed
as micromanagement it actually is
say hey put this over here put that over
here wait back off let me do this no no
you don't know how to do it so I got to
show you how to do I'm teaching you how
to do it so there's that and and then
that's teaching and then sometimes you
got to show people how to do it and I've
told that long story in here one time
where I just said hey you sit and watch
how I'm gonna run this squad
and I ran the squad and got fired up and
told people where to go and move down
the line and the platoon commander
looked at me and said okay I can do that
and as soon as you saw it one time he
got it so that's sometimes
micromanagement is okay the thing is you
don't want to get stuck in the rut of
micromanagement so if I mentor you if I
teach you if I instruct you if I show
you the way
it doesn't mean stay there and keep
micromanaging because you're not doing
your job you shouldn't have the
capability or the capacity to
micromanagement to micromanage everybody
that works for you if you have that
ability you're not doing your job you're
not looking up the chain of command
you're not looking out your troopers
your subordinate leadership should be
stepping up and leading and you should
expect that of them and if you have to
micromanagement it should be a chore
that you don't like doing and when you
get in there and you micromanage for a
certain amount of time then you say okay
you got this you you know I'm I'm
stepping back and then you got to step
back because no one likes to be
micromanaged so once you get people up
to speed step back let them run let your
leaders lead yes sometimes people who
like to micromanage or they feel
compelled to they can fall in that trap
where where let's say they do need to
micromanage and they'll get that payoff
of oh yes guys kind of getting it but
instead of understanding the full scope
of things where oh he's getting it now I
need to I don't need to manage as much
they'll be like they'll still start
chasing that payoff of them getting it
with their little micromanage yeah you
know so they like constantly need that
payoff yeah some people now that you
mentioned some people micromanage
because their ego though they won't want
to they want to exercise they want to do
two things exercise their power over the
person hmm or or show off their
knowledge to the person yeah so those
two are just such a pain
yeah there's such a pain but you know
what what do you do okay cool
I'm gonna work harder I'm gonna be ahead
of you I'm gonna get better at this and
we're gonna move on yeah that showing
off knowledge thing that that that it's
in a micro management situation it seems
like okay it's obvious you shouldn't do
that and you could probably see it from
a mile away but but just in everyday
life that's a compelling thing to wanna
show people you ever you ever hear
someone telling you something that you
already know and you just want to tell
them but I already know I know I know
you know like you don't have to explain
it to me when really when you really
kind of search your own feelings it's
new it's not that they're wasting your
time it's kind of that you just want to
let them know that I have that knowledge
don't worry but you know I mean I'd see
that all the time I feel that all the
time she's got a thank you Tom
but I think that's that's a real
compelling like one desire you know to
to show hey I already know that or look
how much I know you know yeah people
definitely like that it's it makes me
feel good and look at what I know you
know